first up we all love to pamper our
animals
clearly but travel and leisure reports
that you can now
check in your dog your little fur muffin
into the first ever luxury hotel for
dogs it's called
urban mutton london's west end and it's
like
soho house for your dogs darling it
costs 200
to join and then you can sign your fancy
fur ball up for fitness classes
spa treatments or an overnight stay in
an indoor sleep hut with mood lighting
and room service
doggy acupuncture massage and reiki
they're all on the spa menu
ross would you check those chihuahuas in
uh yeah i'm actually really impressed
with you just side note
i would bring my dogs there i have to
say you know i um
they're not like spoiled necessarily at
least that's what i thought to myself
but then i was
i was thinking about massage for dogs
and then i remembered
i one time had a massage therapist come
over to massage one of my dogs
because she had she had little legs
issues and she had surgery and i
was worried that she was sore and so it
turns out these crazy people that spend
this money on their dogs
i you know what
i need to check myself into this hotel
that's what i've just surmised your
story ross
save her spot at the doggy hotel all
right next
i know we all want to support our
favorite local restaurants and give them
give them a chance to thrive again right
well a writer at food and wine
has a great suggestion on how to do that
try an early bird dinner
making a dinner reservation for 5 or 5
30 helps restaurants fit in more
seating every night because they have a
ton of demand for that 7 30 sort of
prime time spot so why not take an early
slot and beat the crowds by helping your
favorite
favorite spots fill their seats now i do
this
because i live my life like an active
senior citizen
i like i do i wake up early i love a 5
30 dinner reservation because then by
seven i'm home in elastic watching 90
day fiance like a normal person
do you this is not a joke do you like
early dinner
um i think basically and it's funny
because my sister
jill cargmen um literally
everything is like on the later side for
her
and we always like and she won't bend
too she knows very much like what i like
and what i don't like and
she just a lot of people really think
that dinner
is between seven and eight and then goes
to like 9 10 11.
i i can't do it i if it's
if it's too late i'm just not in it's
like i'm
so tired by that time then i'm just
resenting
the people oh god i've become bitter
yeah
it just happened officially no i really
i don't get
the late dinner thing no because then i
haven't eaten until i get there at 7 00
pm and when i see you i'm like yeah yeah
let's get appetizers i don't want to
talk to you yet because i'm starving by
the way
you know what i really hate ross go
coffee
at the end of the dinner i'm like
have to sit there and watch you drink
gosh
darn it so you had appetizers you've had
dinner you've had that you've had
dessert and you're like okay i'm gonna
get out of here and they're like do you
have any cappuccino
yes and i'm like why are you drinking
coffee at night anyway what's wrong with
you
that's a good 30 35 minutes you're
sitting there more sit here make
chitchat while you caffeine up at 10 p.m
10 p.m god it's just like i realize at
that moment we're just no
we have nothing in common no it's just
i'm sorry but this is just not going to
work
but you and me ross will do early bird
special
no coffee no you nuts no coffee
no i gotta get home by six i want you to
look at my face when people order coffee
yeah here let's try it ready
um can i get a coffee
look at her
[Laughter]
all right ross now i know you love to
get down and dirty with a stain
oh my not as much as you do but i do
love getting it clean
okay well i am so excited about this
because
if you are into stain removal well then
you are for ross and i and we'll see you
at dinner at 5 30.
yahoo life reports that tick-tock is
freaking out over the stain
removal okay it's the powers of
something called
the pink stuff hashtag pink stuff
has over 57 million views and people
say it can remove any stain from any
surface
and it's only 10 bucks on amazon
nothing's ever turned you on more than
this has it you
you love a stain remover i'm so hot
right now
it's like you could go to thunder from
down under our magic
mic i want to stick ones in this
pink stuff i do i want to stick single
dollar bills in the g-string of the pink
stuff i was trying the whole time you
were talking to get it open and i still
can't do it by the way
because i've realized it's right here
understood
i think i
um okay first of all
oh that's delightful yeah it doesn't
smell like very chemical it's like it
smells like taffy
we have a stain right here i i'm also
like disappointed by this challenge i'm
not gonna lie you guys have got to give
me like
tar on a white tank top but hold on this
could be baked in
by the sun this could be impossible to
get off
you excited by that you know what i am
just feeling like
maybe that i wouldn't mind like a
tougher challenge how about you
you think this is too easy to get off
way yeah so do what do you want to do
you want to try something harder
yeah i was thinking maybe we could do
something like get
you know multiple surfaces and stains
that are really challenging and put this
57 million views and counting
new revolutionary stain removal
available at amazon for ten dollars
and literally the thing people are
freaking out over
people put it in like their car cup
holders apparently you can clean steel
with it
so i'd really like to put it to the test
are you going to think about this all
night long
when i go to bed at 9 00 pm of course
when most people are entering the
[Music]
restaurant